[Music]  I'm here practicing for the rifle hurry  rage a team mountain biking event down  at the Ashley River on Sundays the 12th  of March the recovery rage is the fix  our event in which teams of two to four  riders compete in a relaxed and social  atmosphere riders young and old of all  abilities have been safely in a fun  environment you might wonder why I'm  riding down here at the Dudley Aquatic  Center well all proceeds from the event  go towards supporting the main power why  swim program which teaches our kids to  swim and be safe in the water so whether  you're a local wearing speed freak or a  weekend forea there's a place in the  rocket hurry Rach for you get a team  together or your family and come and  join me on Sunday folks at once the race  is open to all riders 12 years and older  with a variety of categories to suit  everyone in anyone click on the link  below to find out more and register  [Music]